i got this job and i had to put a budget
together in i think it was about three
weeks
and i thought that would be the hardest
thing that i'd ever have to do in my
professional life and it turned out that
that's probably the easiest thing i've
had to do
in the six months or so that i've had
the job
[Music]
you know i wasn't massively into
politics when i was that young
the inspiration for me was my parents
mom and dad my
dad's a gp was a gp where i grew up my
mum
was the local pharmacist near his
surgery and so i worked for my mum
in the shop and delivered prescriptions
out and and helped her and it was
through that that i got a sense of the
difference
they'd made to our community their
patients would always stop and
chat to me about what my parents had
done not just for them but for
generations of their family
this is a unbelievably tolerant
country where people like my family have
been warmly welcomed it's probably worth
bearing in mind i'm not even the first
non-white chancellor
and sad should have the job before me
and it shows
that you actually you you work hard you
contribute
you integrate actually you know you can
achieve your dreams
i got this job and i had to put a budget
together in i think it was about three
weeks
and i at that moment i mean i remember
those three weeks were obviously really
busy and i thought that would be the
hardest thing that i'd ever have to do
in my professional life and it turned
out that that's probably the easiest
thing i've had to do
in the six months or so that um i've had
the job
and we had just kind of you know
summited everest and
actually turned out we were just at the
foothills of like three other mountains
we had to climb we were trying to come
up with policies bran that were brand
new because we're dealing with a
situation that
you know we haven't seen before there
wasn't a playbook for for what you do
when a pandemic hits from an economic
perspective and so the thing i'm most
proud of
is the furlough scheme and we you know
never done anything like that before in
this country
and i've had people in tears telling me
that when they heard that announcement
when we made it it meant
that in their company they knew they
wouldn't have to lay people off which
were they were all about
about to do young people are sadly the
ones that are
most impacted economically by what's
happening we've got
hundreds of thousands of young people
who are entering the labour market for
the first ever time they're leaving
school college or uni
it's a really difficult time and we know
that they're disproportionately working
in the industries that are really
impacted by what's happening for example
in
hospitality or travel for example so
i think it's incumbent on us to make
sure that we step in and provide
opportunities for all those young people
and that's what we've done with
initiatives like our kickstart scheme
it means we're creating really high
quality jobs
for hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of young people who are at risk of being
long-term unemployed and what we want is
for young people not to be the
generation that was scarred by
coronavirus
we want them to be the kickstart
generation and for me it's a matter of
social justice
that we do everything we can to try and
protect those jobs you've been referred
to
in some sections of the internet and in
our comment section
uh i i i struggle to know whether to be
uh happy or or not with that my wife has
a strong point of view but
it's probably best not not not sad today
but you know look
i i i mean as much as i can try and you
know
connect with people and they can
understand what i'm trying to do um
that's a good thing right economic
policy sometimes is a bit abstract from
people's lives
and it shouldn't be because it makes an
enormous difference what do you do
to wind down i am a big star wars fan
yeah there's only i mean there's only so
much star wars you can watch
um so uh you know on a repeated basis
mainly my wife also is not the biggest
star wars fan so
that doesn't work for the kind of shared
experience politics is an area that
uh some young people can feel elite and
kind of
stopped if you could speak to young
people now who might be interested in
pursuing a career in that
area what would you want to tell them i
think too many people think that's not
for me that's something that someone
else should do and it shouldn't be like
that right it's something that
ultimately everyone can do and if you've
got
a set of views and opinions and you
think you can make a difference to your
community by being their representative
it's a fantastic career and i would urge
you to think about it
you know i i did something else first
and that works for a lot of people
i think it helps me be better at my job
today that i bring some experience
from my business career my career
investing in companies
all around the world you know i think
that will make me better at doing this
job for
all of you in the country and then i've
got that experience so i think it's good
to be able to do something else first
often and then
and bring that to parliament um but but
broadly the most important thing is
you know you are there because your
local community elects you
and it's all very well focused on the
ministerial side of it
and and you're here talking to me as
chancellor but your day-to-day job is
being a champion for your local
community right your job is to
hear what they have to say to make sure
their point of view is represented in
westminster and make a difference to
them
person at a time family at a time that's
the part of the job that i love the most
that's why i got into it my dad was a gp
he had surgeries
you know he has patients i'm an mp i
have surgeries and i have constituents
and
my job's trying to help them and that's
without a doubt the most fulfilling part
of the job
[Music]
you can never really be true friends
after something like that
i just don't think it can ever ever
happen
maybe if you fought and it was a draw
maybe you could still be friends but the
idea of
being friends with someone that has a
beating you
it's a hard thing for your head to
compute